this is Jeff Hasson I'm the faculty
chair of mobile for simply learning an
author of two books including the art of
mobile persuasion and mobilized
marketing driving sales engagement and
loyalty through mobile devices welcome
to this introduction to mobile marketing
now what's in it for you first off a
broader view of mobile and its
opportunities for you to reach and
impact your customers and your prospects
secondly through this section you'll
have a leg up on other marketers who
frankly have been slow or unwilling to
adapt in changing times and third I see
an opportunity for you to have new
career possibilities with your newfound
knowledge of mobile marketing and the
morphing consumer now I know that you're
here for a reason
because you know that the mobile phone
has changed the way we live and conduct
marketing but we're not just talking
about any device we're talking about the
most personal one the mobile device and
we as brand marketers want in on the
action what consumers really let us in
or to say it another way if - is company
does three necessarily create a crowd or
could we instead make it easier for the
mobile user by providing value maybe in
the form of just the right offer or
information at just the opportune moment
now even if a consumer gives us an
opening to their mobile lives how are we
as brands supposed to operate with baby
steps or maybe by taking some sort of
permission as a license to put up our
feet on their furniture and stay all
night and what about these
ever-increasing consumer expectations
for gosh sakes I've never ever had a
meatball sandwich from your
quick-service restaurant but you
mr. and mrs. marketer know or should
know from my purchase history that my
diet is vegetarian so why am I still
getting those meatball sandwich ads and
what about the customer journey if I'm
looking at an Armani tie denied online
should you target me tomorrow when I'm
near or in a Nordstrom or is that
personal or is something that's just
plain creepy and what about the
ever-increasing self-sufficient mobile
shopper pushing to examine the very
definition of customer service so we're
here to talk about what's the role of
today's marketer and can we be replaced
by machines but first I'd like to give
you a level set more people on earth
have a mobile phone than a toothbrush or
a toilet wireless penetration in the
United States alone and exceeds a
hundred percent meaning that there's
more than one mobile phone for every
person from coast-to-coast the cell
phone has changed the way we communicate
or don't communicate by share deposit a
check engage our health among tens of
other things that will never be the same
in developing countries the mobile phone
is literally a life line leading to
cleaner water more diagnosis and
treatment of disease and banking for the
unbanked so this all means what as
marketers if we fail to adapt to the
upheaval our customers and prospects
will be someone else's customers and
prospects i've here to say the early
scorecard on our efforts largely largely
shows that we're behind now why do i say
that the trouble is that it comes to the
expectations of the mobile user they're
sophisticated and deserve more credit
than we give them and those who carry
these devices are picking sides so let's
get working on meeting and beating those
expectations